so okay jan's snacking up on a banana
yeah refreshing very healthy okay i was
completely wrong it is the king's pawn
opening and uh magnus now bringing his
bishop out very early so this uh avoids
what we call the petrov defense that was
yandere
uh opening of choice in the world
championship match
and now white's bishop having come out
allows this pawn to push forward without
blocking a bishop in so normally in
openings we say nights before bishops
not this time this is the bishop's
opening and uh jan if he brings the
black knight out from the queen side and
develops it we might see a transposition
to the italian game something we saw
with reverse colours yesterday if he
picks up a pawn pushes it forward that
is maybe a more direct attempt for black
to neutralize white's opening
what will yan do he brings his bishop
out
and uh very sensible stuff by both sides
so far
magnus is going to move a knight which
one is it going to be
i'm expecting his king's night yeah i'm
expecting his king's night as well as i
think it's a bit of a big ask
to develop the other night although it
would make a lot of juniors in the uk
very happy
it's a special specialty of people
living in a county called sussex really
yes uh the county where david's from and
they're all taught this uh certain line
and uh they all the juniors play it why
is that uh
actually there were two or three
openings that in sussex are just
extremely popular everyone plays it with
white and black meanwhile white's
knights coming out here in this game um
i remember when i was young i had a
coach he was maybe the coach who had the
biggest influence on me um he i started
working with him when i was six years
old it lasted for three or four years
the collaboration and the openings he
taught me uh he would basically teach
them to everyone else and
i guess because i was relatively
successful with those openings everyone
started playing them everyone took them
up and yeah it became a badge of honor
that our county were the specialists wow
uh okay meanwhile a few moves white's
knight going to the edge of the board
it's going to trade itself off for
black's dark square bishop so not the
typical italian game that we would
we would usually see
instead white just going for a small
strategic advantage of the bishop pair
and yeah ivanka
he gave me some good memories there i'm
having flashbacks getting nostalgic and
uh magnus doing his favorite plan which
as we've seen time and time again he
loves these flank pawn pushers taking as
much space as possible on the edge of
the board and i have to say it is a rare
move out of all the ones is probably
around about number eight a choice in my
database okay so there's pretty much no
way yanaponnichi would have studied this
exact position
uh maybe he'll have studied something
similar
magnus though doing magnus things we've
seen him before plenty of times push his
pawns forward in front of the rooks on
both flanks especially on this queen
side just trying to gain space magnus
loves his space because later in the end
game his pawns are nearer than promotion
squares maybe he's clamped down on some
weaknesses white's a pawn pushing
forward just fixing the black doubled
pawns on the b-file
where they are and okay some mysterious
bishop moves from both sides
i'm struggling to understand those to be
honest but either way i'm expecting both
sides to castle their kings to safety
and yeah still a lot of tension there we
go black's the first to castle
white does the same
and
despite the fact this is relatively
balanced relatively level position still
as usual between these two far from a
draw
and black's knight meanwhile going back
it's going to step over to the king side
a very typical formation those two black
knights are going to sit next to each
other and act as guardians of the black
king
all right well that black king looks
super safe tucked in with a bunch of
pieces now
as
since you've only played chess for a few
years now katrina what sort of tip um
has been the most helpful for you to
sort of improve the most
i think for me it was
all about the puzzles i did a lot of
puzzles when i started because that was
actually the first thing i did when i
went to university i had time to do
puzzles and sometimes i didn't have time
to do games so in between classes i
needed to think about something else i
did a lot of puzzles and then i saw
patterns and then just grew on me with
these puzzles and i did a lot of them
and then
a few longer games but i played a lot of
games as well yeah so playing a lot
doing puzzles and then i didn't read
much about it i watched a few youtubers
yeah creators and then a lot of twitch
yeah well so yeah that's what that's how
i got into it wow well that's a formula
you like as well right you like
especially the puzzles
i love the puzzles yeah and uh
what annoys me a little bit is that
magnus carlsen did his nasty magnus
class at age ten that was yeah he did a
nasty little tactic that you know i've
been training every single day you know
it's not a lie that i'm on chess 24 um
solving puzzles because i'm dying to get
like a 100 record and i always get one
question wrong and so i'm really annoyed
that you know he tricked me with a a
puzzle over the tactic yeah i just oh
yeah but i definitely agree tactics are
really good and i also can recommend you
know chess of all courses to be honest
i'm a big big fan of that you know i try
as often as i can to
just go on to the move trainer and just
drum in my opening repertoire and i have
to say
from these last two tournaments i played
i cannot fault my openings yeah the
problems happen much much later every
single opening has gone like a dream and
i've remembered things as well because
normally i get surprised and like oh i
don't remember what to do and this time
i was like no no no no no no
okay i'm giving away all my practical
secrets like you know it's quite obvious
which courses i'm studying with but okay
yeah now i remember what they said they
write and uh
it's been very very handy ah okay
puzzles and chessable you heard it here
faster yes uh meanwhile some moves on
the board white now just pushing a pawn
up controlling some squares we saw a
similar theme in the first game katrina
mentioned this white pawn push on the h
file just covering some squares stopping
any pins uh also i quite like what black
has done just from a strategic point of
view black's dark square bishop got
traded off for a night very early in the
game and now in order to exert maximum
influence in order to fight for the dark
squares black has put his central pawns
all on those squares so uh black
structure rock solid also this last
bishop move hinting that black might try
and break through in the center at some
point and open things up at the right
moment
white bishop white's light squared
bishop is normally the pride and joy of
the italian game but look at that white
uh white light squad bishop all of its
pawns are also on light squares it's a
bit trapped you've got to be a bit
careful of that piece
later in the game so
really really complex still it's as if
both players they're just kind of just
feeling each other out tiptoeing around
each other in every single game for the
first 20 moves and then it explodes so
i'm expecting the same this time
hopefully for the game to explode a bit
later for now both sides just marking
out their territory just putting their
pawns on decent squares and okay magnus
going for a pawn sacrifice your banker
what do you think of this one this pawn
push happened just one move ago or no i
mean a few moves ago and now he's pushed
it one square further yeah i have to say
this was actually my first instinct you
know because i feel like you know you
should be doing something concrete here
otherwise black will be the one who has
the plans and what is just kind of
drifting with the two bishops so i do
really like this i mean presumably the
idea is simply if black does get greedy
and just uh captures that pawn that's up
for grabs you know with either the
bishop or the rook then the plan is to
lock that bishop out of the game and
just push forward with b pawn one square
and then just say okay
look at that your position is only as
good as your worst place piece i don't
know where that quote came from i don't
even know whether it's true but for here
it fits so i'm going to stick with it
and
you know just play around that piece and
try to win it simple yeah that's the
thing the bishop is trapped you don't
even need to win it on the next three or
four moves you can just win it long term
for example at some point white might
step up the rook slide the queen across
and then target this bishop um yeah i
mean this bishop there's just simply no
way is going to escape if white's if
black
steps the queen forward attacking this
white pawn in conjunction with the
bishop then white can just do the same
slide the queen across defend this pawn
and there's still no way out this bishop
completely caged so i doubt we'll see
janaponici get greedy and take up the
challenge of capturing this pawn same
thing if he takes with the rook we would
just see a trade and the white pawn
stepping forward would cage this bishop
i think that's too greedy but if jan
can't do that then magnus's last move uh
has been justified if black can't
capture this pawn white might well just
step up the pawn anyway kick black's
bishop back and will have gained time uh
other ideas for white includes sliding
the queen across maybe lifting it up the
board teaming it up with the bishop
against the black king
suddenly yeah the more i look at it the
more i think maybe this pawn push is
just really clever from magnus some risk
involved but yan will he burn time even
contemplating this
uh this capture which might well
backfire or will he just accept that
magnus has gained some space with these
white pawns and just continue developing
the black pieces
i don't think as well just to mention i
don't think black really should capture
on this square
the idea i guess would be after bishop
takes born to now win a pawn because
this bishop can't get trapped but white
could simply step back with his bishop
defending this pawn and capture this guy
at his convenience we talked about
doubled pawns maybe we need a rhyme for
triple pawns
look at these triple phones here
isolated as well i uh i don't know a
rhyme for them but i i think they're
called trunk pawns drunk yeah i've heard
yeah drunken poor drunken pawns yeah
i actually so i went to tata steel to do
some interviews with the players there
and uh on that day
uh anish kiri he actually had triple
pawns in the game and i talked to him
afterwards and i said anish you had
triple pulls i don't think i've ever
seen it and he said
kaya you're so new to chess
so
it looks strange to me but i guess it's
not
that crazy
it's kind of rare though okay i mean
thank you i mean when i
think back to my own chess games i've
only ever
maybe had
drunken pawns triple pawns twice in my
life
and it's so rare to see them i mean
sometimes they're useless sometimes they
control a lot of squares you know it's
like they're doing a little conga they
can't touch this [ __ ]
that's how we call it now um so
yeah okay but in the meantime i do have
to draw attention to the position
because uh napoli actually has uh well
you know he's kind of thrown through and
thrown down the gauntlet in a different
way he's kind of said well let's explode
open the center
yeah and really combative really
challenging uh idea there from yana
pomneichi not just letting the play
happen on the flanks but following
conventional wisdom one when your
opponent's pushing on the flanks counter
in the center and the evaluation part
doesn't like this i do see that white
can grab a pawn
again it will lead to a really weird
pawn structure if white does do this and
get greedy but then again if white isn't
able to find something immediate then
the pontiac's idea will be justified
especially if this set of bishops the
light squared bishops get traded black's
queen coming to the center for example
black is doing great so if we jump into
the position just to show the ideas for
both sides as mentioned if bishop takes
bishop black is doing fantastic here
these knights not just great defenders
but could jump into the game later
with effect black's pawns relatively
strong for now
the alternative for white would be in
this position to capture a pawn get
greedy but after a trade on this square
and after another capture suddenly
whose pawns are weaker these double
pawns look like they are ripe for
picking after black's queen enters the
middle attacking the rook as well
attacking the pawn next to it and
white's a pawn up but that pawn will
drop this one
to me looks very healthy for black i
don't think black's ever better but
unless magnus finds something special
something really magical he's going to
struggle to find an advantage
interesting and now we do have the conga
pawns that we now have have introduced
and katrina from
obviously streaming and uh and playing
at the same time do you have like names
for some pieces or some structures that
you use while you play
we have tricks like kyle into thinking
that names and vines are like mainstream
do you have any catchphrases when you're
streaming yeah yeah like i call my pawns
for princesses
yeah so i used to have it for for them
but not
not like harry or anything like that i
don't want to
make names for them but
like
it's it's funny when you have that
because i see now
as uh simon has his course he has like a
hairy course
so he's making fun of that like or not
making fun of it but he's making
something that is funny yeah yeah
exactly and i mean for beginners and
definitely for kids as well it must be
so much easier to learn chess when well
you can actually um you know imagine
something or have some names for these
pieces yeah definitely for players who
are first starting the game it becomes
more memorable and as katrina says it's
just fun and uh yeah also one of the
biggest streamers uh in the world hikaru
nakamura i mean he has nicknames for
pieces he calls them he calls pawns
juices
he's just popularized just with all
these kind of yeah fruity nicknames and
things and fruity yeah
i don't know it's uh it's stuck in my
brain these days as well i never used to
do it but i do now and talking of fruity
moose this pawn push by yana pognechi
after magnus had run away from the
bishop trade which i mentioned would
suit black yan has pushed in the center
he's really trying to just clarify
everything simplify everything trade off
all the pawns
the downside for black is that opening
the position might favor white's bishops
long term but if black is able to
eliminate the white bishops
before the position becomes too open
then i think black should be fine
i must admit i'm surprised the
evaluation bars so far in white's favor
because
okay it's not a huge advantage but to me
on the board it looks like uh jan is
just doing everything right to
neutralize magnus's uh first move
advantage to the advantage of the white
pieces
now we see more trades and yan just
looking off to the side he's comparing
maybe two or three moves he can take
back this pawn that has just moved for
white with his own pawn with the black
pawn or he can capture white star square
bishop with the black knight and to me
both moves look pretty much fine
i
yeah i definitely think yan is doing all
the right things here and
on the clock as well
very very um nice situation for the
russian player
yeah i i agree there david i quite like
black's position i mean my instinct is
actually to capture off the bishop
because the position is relatively open
and you know even though the knight is
in a really good square
and he does it the bishop might have
long term potential and yep you're right
he does it
and uh
that's a beautiful light square bishop
that black has is sitting in the middle
of the board and uh
i guess you have to capture with the
knight or
can you can kind of offer
can you kind of think can you clean text
queen takes and just kind of go into an
end game yeah just judging by magnus
kind of blinking a lot normally when
he's blinking a lot it means he's about
to do something a bit surprising um just
from when i've played him
he's just calculating something
counter-intuitive
and i just have a feeling he might be
tempted to take with the white queen
here um let's
go into the position maybe if we can
keep an eye on the players as well we
might see a reaction there might be some
surprising moves but uh right now white
has to take this piece back two options
take with the knight which is very safe
okay he does actually do this the reason
i was maybe expecting the queen to take
is because yes bishop takes knight will
shatter the white pawn structure but
once the queen's come off we will see
that maybe this pawn stretcher
can be defended meanwhile white having a
very strong bishop here stopping blacks
rook from coming out
stopping black from challenging for some
open files and in a position like this
if white can maybe trade off the rooks
if white can get his king active maybe a
small advantage because pawns on both
sides of the board favored the bishop
over the night but magnus he decided
doesn't want to take the risk of having
these weak pawns instead capturing with
his knight and now jan
seizing the ball by the horns not just
playing the safe move pawn takes porn
we've seen this time and time again from
him in this final playing brave chess
playing courageous chess jumping in with
his knight and going for the white king
also i mean this queen is going to jump
in with some serious checkmating ideas
a bit scary for magnus now
he has to answer a serious question also
i don't think much risk for yan because
very minimum later he can capture this
pawn later anyway and restore the
material balance
so magnus has to deal with this square
the g2 square is attacked by black's
knight and black's bishop how would you
deal with this
i'm not sure maybe you have to bring
your knight to the center
although this leads to massive
complications as well blocking this
bishop but then you have to work out for
example what happens if the pawn pushes
to destabilize your knight
really really complex no easy choices
actually you know because the more i
look at it the more i'm like oh okay you
know because if maybe you know the
knight decided to move to a different
square to block the diagonal to the f3
square then
maybe this is just again a red flag you
ignore the pawn that's up for grabs and
then you just introduce your queen into
the game and suddenly you're threatening
like an even worse threat which is
knight takes pawn check and
there is like it's going to explode away
all of white's cover and
yeah just to show your idea ivanka check
distracting away this white pawn from
the defense of this white knight now the
queen protects the bishop and uh not
only are you attacking the queen but
checkmate is coming i'm going to slide
the queen across and trap this white
king so i would i would strike that with
that move out actually immediately and
then that leaves another last option
which is really passive
but who knows it might be the only one
which is actually well i don't know the
bishop can come all the way back to its
starting square
dropping the bishop back keeping the
king safe defending the square as you
say last resort right
yeah
i think if magnus has to play a move
such as retreating his bishop back then
the momentum would change in black's
favor at the very minimum again black
could just take this pawn and black has
very active pieces look at these guys
still at home asleep
not having made any moves really and
magnus big big question for him is he
going to block the attack against this
pawn or is he going to just ignore it
and maybe go on the counter
despite the evaluation here the computer
evaluation magnus is the one under an
attack
wow
do you right now looking at this game 20
moves into it also with the clocks
ticking
will this one end up with a winner or do
you think it's most likely a draw
we've said it before right every time we
say there's going to be a winner it
turns into a draw even if it's a crazy
position so maybe if we say it will be a
draw then there'll be a winner
yeah um yeah anything is possible in
this game okay yeah still early days all
right well we do have those double pawns
on the board how did the queen's gambit
sort of affect your interest katrina
because that must have come out
about the same time that you started
streaming yes exactly it did i know that
i watched a queen scan that
really like when it came out i saw all
of it yeah again almost in one second
so it was really interesting to see i
i think it's good for women also to be
shown in chess
and
seeing that you don't have to be
rich to play chess as well yeah there's
like a lot of different stories in this
series so i think it was a really good
series for a lot of reasons yeah i
really enjoyed it as well yeah me too
for popularizing chess definitely and
women in chess i mean ivanka you
obviously pay attention to to women and
chess as well is there
someone a young girl somewhere in the
world that sort of chess world is sort
of hoping maybe will will take that
final step to the top of chess right now
well there's there's um one who everyone
is very excited about a young russian
girl called alexander goriskina okay and
she's being groomed as the next woman's
world champion but i noticed that she is
also playing in the strongest male
events and open events called and uh she
when we came to the grand swiss for
instance um there was one for the open
and one for women exclusively for women
and she was playing in the open
and uh she was also playing not in the
russian women's super final she was
playing in the mail the open cp yeah and
she she did she did really really well
and uh she's being groomed as
big things and so just to go to the
board because we saw magnus actually
played the last resort move that we
didn't expect yeah i think magnus maybe
just one eye on the clock realizing he's
really low on time already he decided
okay safety first chess dropping the
white bishop all the way back
uh back to act as a defender and as
mentioned black just regained his pawn
he recaptured a pawn that he had given
earlier in the game so level material
again but if you compare the pieces
black's knight more active than white's
knight that black knight especially
strong also black's bishop with eyes on
both sides of the board white's bishop
just purely a passive piece so
maybe magnus can equalize this position
hold it if he's accurate
but black definitely very happy right
now and jan he's leaning back
he's got to be very content with what
he's been doing meanwhile white tonight
going in this direction very surprising
it's very surprising totally i mean the
first okay
i was just like the first move i was
thinking i was oh maybe i could decoy
the the the light squared bishop and
move it to another diagonal but i see
magnus's plan because at the end of it
i'm uh black is not going to be better
yeah maybe we can show this because uh
the reason we're surprised is the knight
is going off towards the queen side when
actually maybe it is needed later to
defend its king and uh okay black brings
the queen out that's very sensible we'll
look at this in a moment but after
knight takes pawn your bankers move
winning a pawn uh temporarily at least
just deflecting away this bishop as
mentioned from the defense of its knight
suddenly black is a pawn up but after
for example a queen trade uh i'm not
sure which
black rook captures here then this pawn
drops at the end and suddenly alice the
a pawn is gonna match up the board uh
very quickly and also promotes on a
light square so this would have been
good for white let's catch up with the
game um in this position the queen came
out as mentioned now actually three
potential attackers this is a bit scary
for magnus that's why he dropped back
the knight so the reasoning behind that
knight move has been
has been shown he attacked the black
bishop the black bishop retreating and
now he is using this knight as a
defender and harassing the black queen
at the same time
so yeah i was only looking in one
direction with that white knight he kind
of moved over one side just to bring it
back uh centralize it and now
yeah it's uh it feels like magnus has
plugged all the holes with this white
knight this white knight doing a great
defensive job and attacking job
so no leakage no leakage exactly not
right now at least and when the black
queen moves
uh i mean it has to make a decision does
she go this way does she just slide
across uh when the black queen moves
white has more time maybe to develop the
queen start uh starting to create some
threats so yeah magnus actually finding
a really nice maneuver to hold the
balance
and there we go the queen lines herself
up with the white king
very sensible
and uh if black gets the time black
would love to push one of the two pawns
forward either harry the h-pawn or
freddie the f-bomb to kick away that
white knight from its square
as mentioned that white knight is
holding everything together
and jan wants to destabilize it
now this is uh sort of game six in the
match here in the final they played four
games yesterday they were all draw so
the first match was tied this is the
second game in the second match they
drew the first game and if we do have a
winner in today's
rapid match then that player will be the
winner if they draw all the games today
as well then they will head to tie
breaks and i'm mentioning that this is
game six because it was game six in the
world championship match that magnus
carlsen
won
to eventually also win the entire match
and that game lasted for 130 something
moves i mean
there's not that many pieces left on the
board could could this be that long of a
game it would be surprising if it goes
that far yeah but it could well be a
long one uh meanwhile this last move by
by magnus sorry uh caused yan to frown
yan's still frowning
again
i mentioned in the last game magnus's
instincts his spidey senses told him
that there was something in the position
now yan's uh instincts are telling him
the same and while jan has just given up
a piece sacrificed tonight now the black
rook attacking the white queen but if
the white queen moves white is simply
lost black has actually got a
checkmating attack white has to just
capture this black knight bite the
bullet
and uh
it's actually a counter attack against
the black queen so white can play pawn
takes knight attacking the black queen
and white will be a piece up the
evaluation bar thinks
napoleon she's just blundered i think
this is just a big risk uh that he's
taking right now he has seen this and he
thinks he's getting to the white king
and then we saw
white capturing attacking the black
queen no time for black to capture the
white queen black would have just been a
piece down there and uh now
can magnus hold onto his extra knight or
is black's queen gonna sneak in and
checkmate the white king it's one or the
other
and
okay the evaluation bar correcting
itself here
i think this was white's only move
pretty much so i'm surprised it's been
uh
it's been so indecisive the evaluation
it goes back
this just shows how complicated it is
yeah yeah
and uh of course this position is this
crazy now you know the true napoleon
style and uh the question i'm asking is
how is the probably actually going to
justify
this material sacrifice i mean is he
gonna attack the queen is he maybe gonna
bring the bishop down attack the queen
um
what else to do so many choices you
could slide the rook across attacking
the white queen
you could push this pawn forward
attacking the white knight trying to
kick it away just to explain why napoli
actually sacrificed a piece just to show
this last couple of moves um here rook
takes queen was impossible as mentioned
because actually the white rooks
indirectly defend each other black would
just have been a clear knight down so
you need to keep the queens on and after
this
capture by the black queen if the white
queen had gone anywhere else
other than the square it occupied then
the black queen would have indeed snuck
in and checkmated white in the corner
utilizing the bishop from afar as well
this white king would have been trapped
so maybe jan underestimating something
in this position for sure he had seen
this in advance bringing the white queen
forward uh still keeping an eye on this
important square but maybe he thought he
could just slide the rook across maybe
he thought he was just winning here but
white can block this attack against the
white queen just by sliding the knight
back and uh suddenly i think white is
holding everything together because the
queen can also challenge the black queen
still super complicated right now but
white is holding and
black needs to find something i would be
tempted to push this pawn forward trying
to destabilize the white knight but
maybe now white cannot retreat it white
can just challenge the queens such a
complicated position
i'm not seeing the justification the
evaluation bar doesn't see compensation
here for black but from a human point of
view it does still look scary this white
king very very open
jan he played it by instinct but clearly
he hadn't calculated the follow-up now
he's spending the time but it might be
too late he already sacrificed the night
he should have thought for two minutes
before sacrificing
and uh okay i don't see the
follow-through i love you guys i don't
see any full throat either because you
know i was just considering i liked your
move of attacking the knight but uh for
the reason that you showed that looked
very very convincing and then if the
black rook does step uh to the side to
attack the queen then maybe the knight
can retreat itself and just checking or
maybe that that leads to a draw no no it
doesn't need to draw because the queen
can uh this check can be blocked by the
white queen yep i mean maybe his best
bet in this position uh instead of
giving this check is to try and uh do
one of simon williams and one of magnus
carlsen's favorite things
go for a swinger use one of these rooks
and swing it across to try to get to the
white king
it still looks pretty scary from a human
point of view i must say
for example i'm not sure which rook you
should use to be honest but for example
this rook
bring it up the board threaten a nasty
really nasty check how does white defend
this
um
wow i mean i'm
i'm struggling even now to find a
defense for white maybe you have to be
really sneaky in some variations and
drop your knight back for example
hitting the black queen now
counter-attacking maybe threatening some
background checkmates with the white
queen
it's just a big mess and maybe it's a
mess that favors white but there will be
some tricks along the way and jan very
surprisingly uses this rook to hit the
white queen and uh okay there must be a
reason he left this rook on a square
it's blocked white's queen now hit and
it shuffles out of the way
i'm very very very surprised by that
move actually you know
i i
out of the out of the two rook moves i
mean it's so much more logical to
move to afric
i mean control two lines rather than
control one and that's boxed in yeah and
magnus now following all the rules you
know what move can you now play as a
consequence of black's last move and the
rook was on the the d8 square now the
now the queen can move to the d3 square
and the queen as dave has highlighted
can swing across when she wants to
yeah and uh jan has pushed harry
this h-born marching forward
and okay this must have been his idea
but this is met by magnus just
retreating his knight a really ugly
passive square but it looks fine for now
the only safe square actually because
now a check
from the white king uh from the black
queen to the white king is just blocked
by the white queen
and
if the queen's come off this knight will
activate later and decide the game
white is simply a night for only a pawn
up
and
there's no follow through yeah simply
material is going to decide this game
unless jan now finds something magical
wow
imagine sacrificing a piece and then
realizing it's not really working
it's one of the hardest things in chess
i finished this yarn sort of attacking
again like we saw him do it all day
yesterday i think it's his instincts
that are maybe slightly going wrong here
you know he's like okay well this would
be dangerous let's not calculate let's
just go for it
and uh
magnus is just using brute calculation
just to work himself out of danger
well jan
he has said it in interviews because of
uh of course uh his mind is also
with everything that's going on in the
world being in russia he's been been
worried about the the situation so he
has said that he's been playing on
intuition and it's been working
great for him
is this maybe now the moment where his
intuition failed just a little bit yeah
the thing is with chess is that you kind
of it's not just intuition it's also
calculation it's also knowing what
positions to go for it's also in-game
it's also opening it's just the whole
storybook so um you can't just rely on
good instincts you have to back that up
especially when it comes to critical
decisions like this giving up a piece
there's no way back because you know
it's do or die roll the dice because if
it goes wrong it's going to go seriously
wrong and one thing i really wanted to
mention about magnus's position is take
a look at the queen and i look at how
she's always within touching distance of
her king
and this is a really good defensive kind
of strategy
i just say this because
i once played partner chess with my
husband
and we had a similar type position where
our king was exposed but we had a piece
up and he went off with his queen to the
other side of the ball
born hunting and i was looking at him in
shock and horror and i was like no
[Laughter]
that queen should be there protecting
her king and uh yeah well i'm taking
notes on that as well okay queen in uh
in touch with the the king yep yep you
need her just one move away from sliding
across to the defense and that's where
she is right now and if the white queen
does get that time to slide across trade
herself off it's just going to be game
over magnus is going to win i was just
looking at the amount of time spent as
well jan only spent 48 seconds to give
up a whole night you can't calculate
this type of position in 48 seconds
maybe just a case as as you guys
mentioned trusting the instincts a bit
too much there not calculating and uh
chess you've got to calculate concretely
you've got to see every single option
every single defensive resource for your
opponent especially before you make a
big investment like giving up a night
uh so okay right now he has been
thinking for a long time jan but it's
too late and okay he lifts his rook up
the board so as mentioned trying to
swing that rook across to check the
white king from the front but this rook
can just be traded off and
after this exchange black hitting the
rook in the corner the white rook
uh
in the eye line of the black queen but
that attack has been blocked
and yeah black is running out of pieces
to go for the white king now running out
of time more importantly yeah a black
rook not contributing no i mean i mean
if the
the rook could kind of develop that
skill that
lets you
walk through walls
that would be that would be kind of
maybe that's a new idea for a chess
variant you know at some stage you can
have your rooks just okay
anyway black's rook could just turn into
a knight just for one move and kind of
hop over a pawn kind of slide one square
across and then transport teleport back
into a rook uh transformed then that
would actually be winning
yeah unfortunately not possible not
legal right now yeah
well uh
we have seen this situation before i
feel in the final the bar all the way
over to magnus's side but then he has
stepped wrong is that uh is that a big
risk for him in this situation or is it
quite easy for him now well it's never
going to be easy for him because his
king is in danger
and until that situation is resolved
then he can sit back and enjoy the extra
piece until then it's just defense
consolidate repair work all the way all
the way yep and this position
it looks like he should be able to get
there but with three minutes on the
clock your king's slightly airy
yeah it's definitely not a given uh in
the last game of yesterday magnus it
felt like he just relaxed one move too
soon but if you look at his body
language now he's not relaxing at all
he's still focused on finding the best
defensive moves
um yesterday yeah he was completely
winning he was actually just a rook up
and just two or three accurate moves he
would have won but a similar case today
i doubt we'll see the same mistake twice
from the world champion and okay now
offering to trade off the bishops very
sensible trying to get rid of one of
black's best attacking pieces that black
bishop has been cutting the board in
half controlling some key squares black
now creating a pin
hitting that white bishop with the queen
and with the bishop himself
but this can be blocked yeah i'm
expecting white to offer trader queens
as you say yeah and white tonight could
even step in the way i think two good
moves two good defensive moves
and yan looking off to the side
sometimes he does that when he's trying
to recall things trying to remember but
now he's doing it because he knows his
position yeah it's getting worse and
worse
i think he was even uh speaking
something say something out loud his
frustration you're probably used to that
katrina yeah screaming you're used to
speaking out loud even if it goes
good or bad definitely and
i know that people are watching all the
time so i have to be careful sometimes
what i say
and i try to be teleproof when i play my
own games but sometimes you feel like oh
i should have seen that and you just
want to scream sometimes
from what i've heard uh david has also
he likes to talk when he plays bullet
with himself
i think we did have a little i think we
did have a little beep when you did lose
to minus ten
play minus
yeah and uh yeah katrina as katrina
mentions actually one of my neighbors
knocked on the on the door one morning
in my flat okay magnus just trying to
trade rooks now getting to safety but
yeah one of my neighbors knocked on the
door he was like oh i think i heard a
woman screaming
but it was actually me cursing myself
after losing a bullet game
so
it happens to us all yeah chess will do
that to you definitely it can be
extremely frustrating i have someone at
home playing chess as well and there are
some marks in the floor in the tv
plates have gone
yeah yeah
you know
it's it's it's you know you just kind of
maybe the mouse that's the only thing
that's forgivable yeah the mouse
we've actually seen yarn do that in the
middle of the champion's chest or he
just threw his mouse
right yeah i mean that's that's the
person that you take it out
not plates
not uh computers all right well we see
some mouse throwing from yarn after this
game i don't think we'll see any mouse
throwing because
in a way magnus has just played really
smoothly and i think the top players
they accept it when their opponents play
well often the mouse throwing the
cursing the the anger comes when they
feel they inflicted the defeat on
themselves and uh let's just catch up
with the current game bishops came off
the board rooks came off the board black
actually won another pawn in the process
so now a quick count shows that white
has an extra night but black has two
pawns in return so some compensation at
least but the problem is black's pawns
are far far away from pushing or
promoting
they are not dangerous at all so white's
knight at some point will start to
coordinate with its queen and the white
queen and knight together should
overwhelm black's forces
the only thing you have to be really
careful of here with white is to not go
too far away uh from your king with your
knight because then some checks might
come but
it feels like a distant dream right now
for the pontiac to ever get that type of
perpetual check that will save him so
white meanwhile centralizing his queen
this is what magnus loves to do
and he's got all the time in the world
uh to start improving the white knight
there we go the white king's super safe
tucked away in the corner
and this is why also having a queen in
the middle of the board is so good it
stops potential checks from the enemy
queen
and yan meanwhile at least hitting a
pawn he's trying to make it as difficult
as possible he's fighting
credit to him
and uh okay
can we see magnus
messing this one up i don't see him
personally maybe i mean but it does
require a lot of help from
magnus i mean one idea that i can see in
conjunction with this perpetual check is
actually the creation of a past pawn say
for instance you just push your pawn the
b7 pawn move it up two squares and then
you know instead of capturing back you
try to run with your own pawn but
unfortunately
now magnus has put his knight in the
center that's never ever gonna happen so
okay well yeah he tries the more pawns
that do disappear the closer black gets
to a draw if the queens come off at some
point if white only has one pawn
remaining maybe you have some chances of
eliminating the remaining white pawn uh
so if white's two pawns disappear then a
queen trade would actually save black
the problem is now after this uh kind of
transition that you mentioned ivanka of
the pawns being traded white's knight
and queen are combining and they are the
most fearsome attacking combo and uh
look
okay this is a check but once white's
king retreats or wow steps up the board
super brave by magnus the white knight
is threatening some deadly checks
already look how centralized the white
queen and knight are this is
a really instructive technique from
magnus carlsen centralized pieces
especially queens and knights
often cause a hell of a lot of damage so
white's king joining the fun i know it's
going to do a little bit of a king walk
isn't it because uh the knight and the
queen are going to coordinate so
beautifully on those dark squares as you
mentioned king is now going to
all the way up to the h6 squares who
doesn't like a king walk um
it's it's game over yeah wow this is
really reminiscent of a really of a
famous game in 1991 between uh nigel
short and yan timmon where the white
king did this it went on the dark
squares and it just zigzagged into the
black position and uh a nice checkmate
at the end the white king maybe is gonna
be the supporter uh it's gonna close the
mating net around the black king and
that's why jan
moves his queen down one square he's
stopping the white king from continuing
to advance
and uh okay is there a deadly check can
the white knight jump in with a check do
you just push this white pawn forward
and uh this white pawn that's attacked
by the black queen
that would be maybe too brave
but at the very minimum you give a check
with the white knight and then you start
to think
minus less than two minutes on the clock
right now what what more would you make
if you were whiter katrina i think i
would push the pawn and then i would get
my king out to age six right walking the
king because i just had a mate like that
like last night or something really yeah
uh where i walked my king up and i don't
think that the opponent thought about it
but then i brought my queen up to the g7
square right in front of the king
and then it was made yeah let's just
show that pattern because pattern
recognition is so important in chess and
it's coincidental that it happens the
night yeah you see this uh by magnus
carlsen but let's keep an eye on the
players as well black's queen came
across because if black had been
careless just to show this pattern the
white king is actually going to act as
the attacker and the white king stepping
in is going to deliver this checkmate
and this would just be game over and uh
okay let's go back to the players
because jan has stopped this idea with
the black queen oh and 100 on the bar
yeah we're about to see checkmate let's
go back to the players can we get their
faces on the camera
white queen is just going to step across
one square it's checkmate next move the
black king is going to move the white
knight will deliver the killing blow
there we go the first win of the final
wow and of course it happens in game six
magnus cross and he wins this game with
the white pieces he goes up by one point
in the final and that means tiana
pogniacci he has now two games
he has to win one of them to take this
to thai breaks if